but like not being able to hug people
not being able to see people for the
most part
uh you know and everybody dealt with
this and a lot of people dealt with
death and sickness and all this and i
dealt with some death i mean you know my
grandfather died right before the
pandemic then my
sister passed away last fall and then my
dog just died
you know so i've had some things my god
man but i
know you know what you know what's weird
is you know i don't really share it too
much i mean i share it on the podcast a
little bit but
surprisingly i'm sort of i was scared of
how i dealt with it because i dealt with
it pretty well
and i don't know if it's medication i
don't
i don't know what it is but like i don't
know if it's you know my sister was sick
for a long time so i think i was
mourning her throughout the years my
grandfather at alzheimer's three years i
was mourning him over the years sure my
dog was sick for a long time it wasn't a
sudden
death yeah and i think that i dealt with
it pretty good but i still
sometimes really want to cry and i feel
like i don't cry enough like i really
want to get it out
and uh i did this breathing exercise
this woman came over the other day
and it was breath work and i hadn't done
it these things where it's like
oh yeah and i'm like oh my god she goes
listen we're gonna do this for 18
minutes straight i go
you're [ __ ] off i cannot do this right
team and
my hands got numb and she goes this is
all normal and then yeah all of a sudden
i start getting emotional
yeah and it was really weird and i think
it helped me so i said i want to see you
again it was a friend's wife and yeah
yeah
she came over but it's those things that
i think i need to do that would
sort of connect myself to the things to
loss to the things that i have dealt
with and
i think because if you just bottle it up
i feel like you need some release
grief is a very interesting um
topic in our in american culture
we we don't uh value it
the same way other cultures do we don't
um
put an importance on grieving
the way uh a lot of uh other cultures do
and it leaves a lot of us feeling
[Music]
like what you're talking feeling that
that that feeling of of
i've skipped a step here you know what's
going on i've missed something there's
an important part of this process that i
haven't
that i that i haven't gone through yeah
that's it and
and it'll come have you dealt with a lot
of death
uh i haven't you haven't you have your
mother and father
yeah and and my i had one grand
grandparent
until i was one grandparent left when i
was born
they they had all passed before i was
born and
wow and so i've only dealt with the
passing of one grandparent
i've dealt with a lot of death in the
last year you know as far as
people passing uh from kovid yeah um
but nothing immediate in my life does
that scare you because it scares me when
you know oh my god if i i can't imagine
losing my you know and i'm not
incredibly close i love my parents but
like i would go i would go nuts if i
lost
any sibling or any family member and
that's like i'm getting to the age where
it's like yeah [ __ ] starts to happen you
hear people die in their fifties
in a lot of my contemplative practice in
my meditation or my prayer i
actually do imagine that i spend time
imagining what it will be like or what
it would be like almost pre-grieving
pre-grieving but also front loading my
gratitude and front loading my
um
my approach to the relationship with
these people you know if i've spent
enough time wondering what my life would
be like without my mother my father my
wife my
my son which i have there
yeah spent very little time delving into
that but
you know we recently learned
of somebody who had lost their son and
and to to to imagine that
and to um to
grieve in a way uh uh
improves my life
so much because i because i when i see
this person my heart
is just when i see you you know to go a
year without seeing you and then to see
you
yeah you know the gratitude rushes back
in i open the front door and i hear you
upstairs playing the guitar and singing
and i'm just like i didn't even know you
were here
well i the door was unlocked i i you're
always welcome to walk in but i didn't
i was playing guitar and i was just
feeling it and playing enough and my
heart
just my heart left for you my friend
cause we would get together before we
did our old podcast together and we'd
play music and we
we play a song i play a song and it's a
beautiful thing yeah